So my dad was an officer
in the United States Marine Corps
for like, 23 years.
You can imagine how disciplined he was
and how disciplined he wanted
his kids to be.
And how much we fucking hated it..
Cause, you know, he would wake you up
at like 6:00AM on a saturday!
And when you'd ask him,
"Dad..
why?"
He'd give you one of those
adult cop-out answers like,
"Someday you'll understand."
So you'd get out of bed
and try to find a place to hide
to get more sleep
and of course he'd find you
and then send you back to your room
to go make your bed.
And when you'd ask him,
"Dad..
why?"
He's give you like,
some half-assed rhyme
that's supposed to make sense
to an 8-year-old.
"Messy bed..
messy..
head."
And don't forget the list of chores,
Obligated reading quota,
and the required
"One sport, one instrument" activities.
Needless to say, my dad was right.
I mean, now that I'm an adult,
I'm incredibly grateful for this structured life.
I mean, he essentially trained me to
value productivity,
self-improvement,
and--and being well balanced.
And you know, my dad
always reminded me of Superman.
You know, like the boy scout, heart of gold,
(accent) Moral compass points north!
(Normal) And I mean, don't get me wrong.
Superman's cool and everything,
but..
I'm a Batman kind of girl, you know what I'm saying?
I mean, I remember--This is a great story,
but I remember when I was 19
I would smoke weed in my room
cause I was a total moron
and I lived at home.
And of course, my dad could smell it
because it's weed
and it reeks
and it travels!
So, whenever he did,
he would come marching up to my room
and you could hear him, because the walls were so thin,
being like, "DUN DUN DUN DUN"
and so I was like, "Oh my god, he's coming!"
and I would run to my bed,
and I would grab a book.
and I would make sure it wasn't upside-down,
and then I would look as concentrated as possible.
So when he walked in,
he would just be ready to let me have it,
but then he'd see me sitting there,
reading a book,
and he just..
he just kinda get--looks..
stops for a second.
And kind of process that.
And, you know, because you can't
really yell at your daughter
for getting high and then reading.
Cause my dad is that guy
who has never tried weed.
So he doesn't know
that you can't smoke
and read a book.
It's like..(scoffs)
you'd read the same sentence
over and over again.
Hi mom.
I know you watch my videos so, uh..
don't tell dad.
Please.
Uh, but I'll see you guys next Monday.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara